what's going on guys this is Rob we're
back with deceased and oh my God I can't
wait to see how you guys feel about the
ending of this story it's it's amazing
right the ending of this is just oh my
God I'm so excited for this so as you
guys know with deceased right to get you
guys caught up on everything because
these issues come out once a month so
it's been a little while since we did
the most recent one so as always you'll
find a link to the DC's playlist down in
the description in case you want to get
caught up but we'll also make a full
story video on the whole deceased event
from beginning to end once this whole
thing wraps up but keeping in mind
what's happened so far is that you
basically have the forces of all those
who are infected by anti-life they're
basically zombies right by all standards
of measurement they're effectively
zombies and they're led by dark side and
they're literally cutting like a swath
through the universe and they're making
their way towards Earth too which is
like the second version of Earth is
basically the the new Earth and all the
different characters of the survivors
basically live on and this battle has
been raging on for a little while right
like it's been going for some time now
at this moment one of the things to
remember is lobo basically steps in now
for those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with Lobo he's amazing but ridiculous at
the same time the idea behind Lobo is he
was designed to be like a DC Comic
parody of Wolverine from Marvel Comics
right they're like Lobos just ridiculous
he's over the top he's nigh
indestructible right it's almost
impossible to hurt this guy if not truly
impossible I mean his healing factors
absurd it's nuts right I mean it's it's
crazy what this guy's capable of the
important thing here though is that
lobo's a guy who is every bit on par
with Superman in terms of power and this
guy's showing up on the scene is a huge
deal because it's not enough to like
turn the entirety of the battle in favor
of the superheroes but it is enough to
help them Stave off their own impending
death a little bit longer but as we know
with deceased this is as much an
analysis of the nature of superheroes as
it is just like an end of the universe
type of event and so what you end up
getting here is of course big Barda and
scot-free right Mr miracle if you're not
familiar with him they're not overly
important the big thing about this
though with their characters is that
they were initially infected a cure has
since been developed but the Cure is on
the old Earth it's not on the new Earth
and so the result is that they don't
have the ability to easily cure people
in this area more so than that while big
Barda and scott-free were cured their
son Jacob has not been cured and in fact
he's infected now and this is where the
kind of personality-driven element of
the story comes into play because one of
the things that happens is while Alfred
pennyworth is basically narrating all of
this stuff one of the things he talks
about is that he never really understood
the kind of sacrifice that a parent
would make for their child until he
became apparent him himself having like
Bruce Wayne is kind of a surrogate son
right really his son by all standard of
measurement and that in experiencing
what it meant to have kids of his own he
understands the sacrifice that a parent
would make for their child and so what
he talks about here is that in this
instance Jacob the son of big varda and
scot-free attacks his parents because
they can't bring themselves to kill
their own child now for Alfred himself
right remember he's basically imbued
with the Specter now of course the
Specter is basically the embodiment of
God's Wrath it's one of the cool things
to know about DC Comics is that like
judeo-christianity right it does exist
in DC the god of Abraham the
judeo-christian God does exist in DC
Comics he's called The Presence but the
thing about the Specter is that he is as
much a plot device as he is an essential
character right like he's a guy who
really just kind of shows up whenever
he's needed and sometimes his power is
enough to just end the threat
immediately other times it's not he's
like the Living Tribunal in Marvel
Comics could he just wave his hand and
end the problem sure but like because of
whatever's going on for some reason he
can't and in the case of Alfred While
You know despite the fact that he's
imbued with all this astronomical power
there is a bit of inner turmoil going on
here the first is that as the the
embodiment of God's Wrath or God's
judgment right the role of the Specter
kind of changes really even just within
the confines of this story it's kind of
nuts that his initial motivation is to
just destroy everything right I mean
it's kind of it's really him fighting
against the nature of the Specter itself
that's what it does it like you know
fire Brimstone the specter's Old
Testament man like he just does that
kind of stuff but Alfred himself even
filled with anger and rage towards those
who were basically zombies and the
sensitives because of them that he lost
Bruce Wayne and he lost uh Dick Grayson
and he lost Jason Todd and the people
who were close to him right Damian Wayne
is the only Survivor that's why he's
taking on the mantle of Batman that in
reality Alfred just wants to annihilate
everything but it's kind of funny
because in the midst of all this fight
right this great big huge fight that's
going on Damien Wayne has been infected
and so seemingly it's only a matter of
time before Damien succumbs to the virus
now how fast people succumb to this is
relative to the importance of the
character right like if someone who
doesn't matter is infected with a virus
they turn immediately if it's somebody
like Damien Wayne it's all hold on as
best I can you know and he lasts just
long enough to basically you know
somehow find a way out of it or
something along those lines and so it's
kind of cool here because what you end
up having is Damien speaking directly to
Alfred and this is one of the huge
things that Tom Taylor did with Damien's
character because when Damien was
originally introduced in DC Comics way
back during Grant Morrison's Batman run
during the Batman and Son story arc that
what we had was Damien who was trained
by the League of Assassins and he didn't
really care he would kill anybody for
any crime it didn't matter what it was
right like those of you guys who
remember the movie Batman Begins when
Liam Neeson's character was saying like
we just need to kill anybody who commits
crime because the reality is that the
criminal justice system basically allows
those individuals who commit crimes to
have a second chance and criminals rely
on that second chance to basically
better their abilities to commit crimes
without getting caught that Damien was
very much the same way Damien was like
if you shoplift you're dead right if you
uh if you dive into a pool when you're
not supposed to you're dead right for
those of you guys who recognize the tick
tock meme no diving but like it's that
kind of a thing right like Damien was
just super hardcore and in fact even in
a lot of ways it was Batman just having
to reel Damien in it was Batman having
to teach him you don't just kill anybody
because they commit any kind of a crime
the reality here is sometimes you let
the small fish go so they can lead us to
the big fish and other times some crimes
just don't matter right like I mean a
person shoplifted it sucks for the
person who owns the store but in the
grand scheme of all the crime time
that's committed in Gotham City it
doesn't really matter all that much and
so kind of reeling Damien in and then at
the same time teaching Damien to kind of
focus on humanity and to focus on the
idea that people can become better hence
the reason why everybody deserves a
second chance that initially Damien
didn't take to it and he very much
rejected it what this story shows is the
evolution of Damien over the years yes
it's an alternate reality story no it
does not take place in the main DC
Universe but the progression and nature
of Damien is still the same and so were
Damian's talking to Alfred and saying
look you can't just kill everybody right
I know you want to I know you desire to
because of all the things that you lost
everything that's been destroyed
everything that you care about Alfred
has been totally destroyed I know that
you are angry hence the reason why you
are now the host of the Specter but you
have to be better than that you can't
destroy everything and even if you
desire to hold off on doing that for me
if you ever loved me and if you ever
respected my memory and what the mantle
of Batman stood for do not go through
and just kill everybody now that's an
important distinction to understand here
because Alfred could do that as the
Specter right he could literally go
through and just annihilate everybody
here and it'd be very very easy for him
to do and so this is one of those things
where like it kind of allows the story
to continue but it focuses more on the
nature of Alfred now for the most part
one of the things that goes on here is
that Alfred starts to realize there's
something much bigger a foot that yes
like Erebus who's kind of like the main
enemy that we haven't really seen yet
but basically the one that is the reason
why this anti-life virus exists in the
first place right so you can kind of
call him the creator of the virus not
really patient zero but the main
catalyst behind all this Dead arabis
starts to realize the nature of the
heroes that they won't stop fighting
that regardless of what happens they
will eventually find a way to win and so
in order to quell that instead of having
this kind of Battle of attrition where
Erebus is just kind of sending his
forces in over time he sends them all in
at once just this overwhelming force and
it's a really smart move to make because
normally you could go with the Battle of
attrition right you could just have a
virtually endless wave of enemies that
constantly come at you and just wear you
down to the point that you can't
necessarily fight but because the nature
of superheroes is that they are all
effectively Mary sues in the sense that
it's like well Against All Odds will
somehow find a way the best way to
defeat them is to throw all your forces
at them at once such a massive
overwhelming force that there's
seemingly no way to win so not only does
Darkseid and all his forces arrive on
the scene Supergirl the whole nine yards
right because she's infected right so
the other thing that happens is war
world follows suit now war world is a
huge deal for those of you guys who
don't know think of war world and DC
Comics it's very similar to like the
Death Star from Star Wars right one it
is an actual world where people just
fight in gladiatorial and gladiatorial
combat right that's one of the big
things about it but the other part of
war world is it is literally a
destructive vessel right it can just
fire off beams of light that will
eradicate an entire planet right and
that's literally what's going on here
that when War World shows up that Alfred
actually takes off what he literally
early lease and he says like I'm needed
elsewhere right there's somewhere else
that I need to be and that leads to
Jonathan Kent the son of Superman
stepping in now remember Superman
himself is off on the other side of the
universe with the Green Lanterns they
split their forces in half one half was
to go save a world that was being
attacked by dark side lest that world's
population end up being turned and
darkseid's forces bolster by like 16
billion with a beat a massive number and
so splitting those numbers in half you
only have really half the superheroes
that are available fighting here and so
Jonathan's stepping in one of the cool
things about his character is much like
Damien's Evolution between being the
just murderous Son of Batman to becoming
an actual superhero Jonathan wasn't
really murderous but he struggled with
confidence he lived under his father's
Shadow right he's the son of Superman
and that in the DC Universe all these
superheroes out there model themselves
in some capacity after Superman he's
like the guy right and so like when
you're the son of Superman you're in the
shadow of presumably the greatest
superhero to ever live and so Jonathan's
evil Evolution as a character was
breaking out from under his father's
Shadow and becoming his own man and one
of the ways in which he does this is
facing off directly against Darkseid now
can Jonathan defeat Darkseid while
darkseid's empowered by the anti-life
virus as well as a Yellow Lantern ring
which basically allows him to feed on
fear and bolster his power no Jonathan
cannot win under that circumstance one
he's not powerful enough and two
Darkseid is far more capable far more
knowledgeable and a lot more experience
in combat than Jonathan is and so
Brainiac ultimately steps in right
Brainiac being like well technically
he's the ninth level intelligence but a
major super villain and so the result of
this is that because Brainiac is by all
standards of measurement a living
computer that Darkseid infects Brainiac
with the anti-life virus which in turn
leads to Brainiac taking off to his own
ship now the reason why Brainiac does
this ties directly into the nature of
Brainiac remember one of the big things
about his character is that over the
years throughout his entire publication
history in DC Comics this guy travels
from one planet it to the next basically
conquering and destroying it but
whenever he does he steals a singular
City from that planet shrinks it down in
order to preserve the knowledge of that
planet and by extension expand his own
knowledge and then he literally just
kind of keeps it as a sort of Trophy and
there are hundreds if not thousands of
these cities because of the amount of
time that Brainiac has spent traveling
the spaceways and conquering worlds and
so when he shows up here that what
Brainiac starts doing is actually just
you know it starts destroying each one
of these cities but then cyborg shows up
now under normal circumstances Victor
Stone is about as useless as tits in the
Warhawk this guy never this guy doesn't
do anything right he starts no useful
purpose but in this story he does and
it's a pretty epic one so because of the
fact that Brainiac is a living computer
and Cyborg is quite literally one half
human and one half machine that where
Erebus in control of Brainiac tries to
infiltrate cyborg cyborg realizes Erebus
can't do that cyborg himself is immune
to the anti-life virus now we've known
that since the beginning but we didn't
know the extent of it and so what this
means is that with cyborg being
impenetrable right somebody that Erebus
literally can't get a hold of that what
cyborg does is he seizes control of
brainiac's Prime Systems if you want to
call it that and absorbs brainiac's
Consciousness into himself quite
literally cyborg merges with Brainiac
and what it does is it not only boosts
the intelligence of cyborg giving him a
much more intuitive understanding of
exactly what he needs to do in order for
the superheroes to win but it also
grants him all the knowledge of Brainiac
himself and that's when he comes up with
an idea and he literally travels back to
all the superheroes and he's like Lois
Lane and she's like yes and he's like
where's Candor and as soon as I saw that
I was like oh my God right like oh my
God because I totally forgot about
Candor it never occurred to me to think
about Candor now we'll talk about why
that matters here in a second but
jumping back over to Jonathan Kent and
his fight with Darkseid he's able to
hold his own to a degree but what
happens is something else catches his
attention and what he does is he raise
is away from the fight and he flies to
war world and the reason why is because
he realizes war world is powering up its
Canon and war world is intending to
annihilate the entirety of the planet
Earth in one Fell Swoop it's a genius
move right send in all the soldiers
right so they're like all the foot
soldiers so that all the superheroes are
distracted and fighting them and in that
distraction use your primary weapon to
take everybody out are some of your
soldiers gonna die sure but if your goal
is to win by any means necessary then of
what relevance are soldiers that you see
as easily replaceable it's diabolical
but it would work and so what's so crazy
about this is that Jonathan is able to
hold off the blast of War World right
saving the Earth but as he falls back to
the planet thousands of kryptonians are
making their way into the battle now
here's the reason why and this is where
it all this is this is where it all gets
nuts Israel gets crazy remember kandor
was a city on Krypton that brainiacs
stole Before krypton's Destruction like
literally kryptonians need to be exposed
to a yellow sun in order for their
powers to thrive and so what happened is
that literally because of cyborg the
various kryptonians in the bottled city
of Candor were freed from their
captivity and returned to their normal
size so now all these kryptonians you
basically have thousands of Superman
just flying around right Superman and
Superwoman this changes the nature of
the battle entirely but but here's the
thing man there's still this amazing
moment that happens to this amazing
moment that comes out right so like
Superman arrives back on the scene right
like him and all the other forces are
basically back in the battle now
Superman of course rescues the sun which
is really really cool and then Alfred
returns with the Cure that he took from
like Earth right like literally brought
just these huge shipping containers full
of the Cure and flew it to the other
side of space in order to basically cure
all those who were infected on Earth too
and so of course Damien Wayne is one of
the people who's cured here but the
other person that's cured is dark side
literally it's one of the coolest things
right so like like you literally have
like you've got you got Mary Marvel
right from the like shazam's sister
basically she's like holding down Dark
Side Jonathan Ken's holding down dark
side and then like Lobo comes up and
just like grabs one of the uh one of the
Cure virals and like smashes it in the
mouth of Darkseid and cures dark side so
then dark side returns to normal right
and then he's like what's happened and
he's basically told by like Alfred and
Superman you were basically infected
with the anti-life virus you are being
used as a pawn now Alfred immediately
wants to destroy Darkseid right he wants
to eradicate him but the response to
Superman is no we cannot kill Darkseid
one Dark Side by himself is more than
enough for any one of us here Darkseid
imbued with the power of a Sinestro core
ring a Yellow Lantern ring amplifies his
power even further right like dark side
is incensed that Erebus had used him as
a pawn in a campaign to conquer the
universe so what does Darkseid do
Darkseid joins the superheroes and turns
against Erebus and that's the thing man
Erebus has no idea what's coming right
it's like that guy in that movie
Ricochet you didn't beat him you just
pissed him off and now you're cause now
he's gonna be out for blood with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace